lang. Auf jeden Fall bis zum Abendessen bin ich am Start. So was trinke. Nachdem wir im
letzten Stream kaum noch ordentliche Battlefield Maps spielen konnten, habe ich gedacht, komm
machen wir nochmal ne Runde. Weil ich mein ich wollt eh offline spielen. Und wenn ich
eh offline spiel, kann ich auch im Stream spielen. Na, da kommen die ganzen Streamschneibers
wieder an den Start. Die nur drauf warten, dass mal einer in der Battlefield 3 Kategorie
spielt, um dann direkt instand nach zu join. Keg Tribble you. Null. Äh Moment, was ist
meine IP hier? 2, 1, 6, 4. Ah, meine IP hat sich geändert. 6, 4, alles klar. Exzellent.
Poggers. Gut. Auf gehts. Schauen wir mal was nehmen wir für nen Server. Was nehmen wir
für nen Server? Was haben wir hier schönes zu bieten? Geben wir uns erstmal, geben wir
uns erstmal den 32, was ist 32? Nose hair canals. Oh Leute, ich muss die Bitrate hochstellen.
Exzellent. Output. Probieren wir mal mit 7. Dann sieht das ganze nämlich richtig Grub
Isp aus. Kucken, ob der Unity Media mitmacht. Oh Moment, ich muss auf Battlefield 3 umstellen,
ich hab das Game noch nicht umgestellt. Kategorien. Battlefield 3. Fertig. Vergessen umzustellen.
So, jetzt sollte eigentlich Battlefield 3 drinstehen. Exzell, auch gehts schon los.
Ok, das kommt ungefähr hin. Auf gehts. Das ist letzte Base. Oh Gott, wir kriegen auf
den Sack, so wie es ausschaut. Huge. Massive auf den Sack. Guck mal, ich komm rein gejolt
und die haben schon gelegt. Vielleicht lief ich den Server gleich wieder. Vielleicht lief
ich instant. Wow, what? Wo? Welcher Server? Es gibt doch nicht so viele. Der einzige 16
versus 16 Server. Jetzt gibt hier der da. Nee, der da. Der da sind wir grad drauf. Mal
schauen. Aber die Runde kriegen wir wieder auf den Sack. Das ist immer so, wenn man
neu reingejolt. Alter, what? Hallo, game. Ja, ist ja gut hier. Oh, oh, oh, den, den
der da. Das Problem ist, rechts ist einer. Ich hab ihn gesehen. Pass auf, der kommt
gleich wieder. Der kommt gleich wieder. Rechts, rechts, rechts, rechts, rechts. Exzellent.
Von hinten kommt einer rein. Alter, was ist denn hier grad los? Kann ich mal zwei Minuten
bitte Ruhe haben? Ich hör sie, ich hör sie. Ich hör sie doch. Ich hab sie doch hier
rein. Wo kommt der Laser her? Paranoia. Ich verpiss mich. Exzellent. Ich verpiss mich.
Da macht er sein 360 mit der UMP, ich glaub's nicht. Kein High IQ Stream. Nee, wir sind
grad erst reingejolt in eine Runde, die schon komplett verloren ist. Komplett lost. Mal
gucken, ob die Balance besser wird. Was messert er ihn erst noch? Ach du Scheiße, da steht
ein LAV drin. Okay, keine Chance. Keine Chance. Ja, man kann von da hinten nicht diffusen.
Das durfte, nee, keine Chance. Lost, base lost. Denn die letzte Base kann man ganz gut
defenden. Ich hoffe, wir spielen danach Attack Attack. Da kann ich euch mal ein paar big
brain Wege zeigen. Aber erste Runde, wenn man in so eine verlorene Sache reinjoint,
ist eh immer fail. Was willst du machen? Ach, das ist unsere. Okay, da geht's ja. Was
gibt's heute zu essen? Wahrscheinlich Pizza. Vielleicht werde ich geschneipt, ich sag's
euch. Wahrscheinlich Pizza, aber das ist noch nicht so hundertprozentig raus. Wahrscheinlich
Pizza. Oh, oh, oh, da kommt ein Amtrak. Alter, äh, äh, äh, äh, oder Omeleeli? Alter,
was ist das denn hier? Oh, ich dachte, ich krieg den, ich dachte, ich krieg den Pilot
noch raus. Ja, so Lost Runden, guck mal, Team auch in Unterzahl, dann machst du nix.
Wenn wir Glück haben, joinen die Leute vom letzten Mal wieder rein, weil die waren massiv
poggers. Poggers. Poggers ist der, der französische, der französische Poggers. Poggers. Hallo,
ich bin stuck, ich bin, ich bin stuck. Okay, ne, da machst du nix. Also, die Runde ist
direkt joined, lost. Mal gucken, ob Auto-Balanced kommt das nächste Mal. Mal gucken, ob Auto-Balanced
ist. Bring es hier hinten, die, die, die Flank-Route ist richtig top. Okay, die wissen, dass ich
gleich re-peake, deswegen gehen wir anderen Winkel hin. Das ist übrigens was, was man
in jedem Game so machen kann. By the way, wenn man re-peaked, kann ich euch nur in jedem
Game raten, wenn man re-peaked, re-peaked unterschiedliche Winkel. Wisst ihr, und schon
funktioniert, oh nein, nein, nein, ich hab nachgeladen, fuck, ich kack nur, ich hätte
noch warten sollen. Wenn man re-peaked immer anderen Winkel, oder mal nicht schneller als
der Gegner, eins vor dem Bein, das geht natürlich auch. Aber die Musik ist ein bisschen laut,
oder? Vor allem ist die Musik übelst nervig, fällt mir gerade so ein. Wir haben Doppel-Squad-Cover,
das ist Low-Brain. Da steht der M-Track drinnen. Monk, kommst du raus, 30 Billionen Gegner
vor der Tür, geile Sache. Okay, ich hoffe, Auto-Balance kommt nächste Runde. Oder wir
hätten von Anfang an drinnen sein müssen. Musik ist richtig. Aber Game-Lautstärke ist
auch okay, oder? Das muss ich übrigens runter machen. Das müssen wir minimieren, OBS. Okay,
gleich zwei Streams, ja, Big-Brain heute. Was haben wir sonst noch für Server zur Auswahl?
Falls der gar nichts wird, das machen wir mal raus. Expansion-Packs hab ich installiert,
Rush, alle Server, voll, und die, die komplett empty können wir rausfiltern. Geht doch noch.
Der ist auch ganz gut, das spiel ich auch öfters mal. Und halt die 64 Mann, die sind
halt brutal. Die sind halt echt brutal. Das ist halt tatsächlich mit der besten Server,
wenn man auf Epic rumgestellt steht. Die hier sind ganz gut moderated, hab ich den Eindruck.
Da werden sogar Leute gebannt bzw. gekickt, weil sie im Chat flamen. Wo gibt's denn so
was? Die Musik ist mir jetzt aber einen Ticken lauter, hör ich im Game nix. Wir machen die
Musikervoll aus. Oh, schau wieder, Dema Van Peak. Die, die wollen, dass wir die gleichen
Maps spielen. Battlefield hat glaube ich 14 Maps oder so. Und Attacker jetzt? Darf ich
Attacker sein? Please, lass mich Attacker sein. Game, Attacker. Auf geht's. Okay, wir haben
Squad Cover, das muss ich danach mal austauschen. Doppel Squad Cover bringt nix. Die BF3 Maps
sind alle ein Genuss. Na, also ich finde Firestorm und Caspian Border ist nicht meins. Aber ist
Geschmackssache. Komplett Geschmackssache. Mal gucken, ob wir unseren Big Brain Flank
machen können diesmal. Was? Mit der Fucking Shotgun über diese Range? Habt ihr das gesehen
mit der Shotgun über diese Range? What the hell? Ich muss mir das Call of Duty springen
abgewöhnen. Ich muss mir das Call of Duty springen abgewöhnen. Ach, der ist verreckt.
Moment, hinter mir ist doch noch ein Teamate. Wie geht das denn? Slugs halt, ja wahrscheinlich.
Wahrscheinlich Schlucks. Schlucks waren's. Schluck Ammo. Oh nee, fuck. Verdrückt. Okay,
mal gucken, ob wir Big, Big, ah wir können, wir können. Wir probieren mal was. Das geht
in der Regel in die Hose, zeige ich euch gleich. Da kann man nämlich manchmal die Schneiber
bashen, die da stehen. Weil hier oben sind immer die Schneibers drauf. Okay, das funktioniert
so nicht. Das funktioniert so nicht, wie ich mir das gedacht habe. Oh fuck, von rechts.
Ja, was ist denn hier los? Das artet ja schon in Spawn Rape aus. Alter, das ist ja wieder
ein Wahnsinns-Rollektor. Ich glaube, ich wechsle gleich so. Kommst ja gar nicht vorwärts.
Da kann man ja noch so Pick-Brain-Plays machen und das wird nix. Ja, das ist so pressen sehbar
und das ist halt. Okay, ihr macht das schon, ihr retzt die. Ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, jetzt
kommt der Heli. Nee, das, wo? Okay, er ist grad wenig durchkommen, muss man sagen, obwohl
die Defender weniger sind. Lass den Server wechseln, der ist garbage. Es gibt nicht
so viele. Er ist einfach nicht balanced, null, null balanced. Hallo, game, game. Das geht,
das geht schon. Oder auch nicht. Aber hier geht wirklich wenig vorwärts. Wir probieren
es jetzt noch und danach wird es vielleicht auto balanced. Ansonsten ist es voll für
den Arsch, kannst vergessen. Vor allem die ganzen Schneiber-Dudes, was haben die denn
hier? Sobald man da einzig ist. Okay. Sag mal, kann mal irgendeiner vorwärts gehen?
Hier geht ja keiner lang, Alter. Was ist denn hier los? Die Making is amazing, hat er recht.
Funktioniert richtig gut. Ja, du hast, so runden hast du in Battlefield teilweise, gerade in
Battlefield Company 2 hast du teilweise so runden. Die sind richtig viel zu Batman. Wir
können es noch mal probieren. Aber ich wäre schon beschossen, Alter. Jeder will nicht
sterben. Nice, nice, nice. Jetzt müssen sie zurück. Jetzt fangen wir sie ab. Sag mal,
leckt der oder? Ich pepege einfach nur. Ich pepege einfach nur. Das liegt glaube ich
nicht am Game. Wobei der eben ganz schön rumgesprungen ist. Nice. Machen wir noch mal.
Scheint ja ganz gut zu funktionieren. Das war nicht der. Hier oben ist Powergas, ich
brauch. Oh, ich hab keine Muni. Okay, okay. Ich hab halt keine Muni, das sagt. Alter,
was brauchst du dafür Glück, dass der mich jetzt messern kann an der Stelle? Nein, nein,
nein. Der nächste. Wir gucken, dass wir das jetzt kriegen. Nice. Ich höre was hochrennen.
Ich glaube, ist alles down. Aber ey, denn der Messer Mann, was hat denn der für ein
Glück gehabt, dass der hinter mir gestanden hat? Huge, big brain stats. Okay, gehen wir
links, rechts. Okay, wir sind jetzt links, wir bleiben links. Battlefield, please, come
on, come on bro. Battlefield, machs mir nicht so schwer. Battlefield, machs mir nicht so
schwer. Okay, diesmal schießen wir den komischen Battlefield. Diesmal schießen wir den komischen
Eliman raus. Oh nice, guck mal, wir kriegen sogar gesmokt. Magic, Alter. Du, ich smoke
da mal bringen, Gegner vor mir. Oh man, geh weg. Okay, okay. Wir lassen die Dudes hier
mal. Oh, der Heliman. Der Heliman, der Heliman, der gefällt mir nicht, der Heliman. Alter,
der Slugsmann. Gucken euch mal an, mit seiner Shotgun über die ganze Map. Bringst links
war was. Ich seh nix. Okay, wir machen das jetzt anders.
Das wird anstrengend gerade gegen die Gegner. Guckt euch mal, die farmen sich hier den Arsch
ab. Oh, oh. Poggers. Ach fuck, das ist ja unser Spawn, Alter. Ich dachte ja schon mal Gegnern
drinne. Muss snipern, ich sniper net. Okay, vielleicht fliegt der jetzt rüber und wir
können auf die andere Seite. Ich mach, lege Hände und kille was, das reicht. Und retz
Leute. Kann ich alles machen. Ich seh den Heli nicht mehr. Okay, jetzt weiß er, dass
ich da bin. Ich steh hier echt. Alter, ich steh hier so schlecht. Was soll ich machen?
Ich steh hier mit dem Heli vor mir, den Gegner. Trash. Trashbalancing. Was ist mit dem Typ
los? Was macht der da? What the fuck? Pepega clap. Was zum Teufel ist? Hat der den Account
bei Ebay gekauft oder was? Bei MMOGA. Da fällt mir jetzt echt nix ein gerade. Da fällt
mir wirklich nix ein. Woher weiß der das denn jetzt schon wieder? Ach so. Woher weiß
der, wo ich bin? Hier ist auch einer. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay.
Hier ist auch einer.
Unter uns ist doch einer. Okay, jetzt können wir mal vorpushen. Jetzt
können wir echt. Oh fuck. Leute, jetzt können wir vorpushen. Push, push. Okay, jetzt pushen
wir vor. Komm, da war doch eben Smoke. Wo sind die hin? Nice, nice, nice. Huge Smoke.
Da schießt. Ja, ist klar. Wie der da durchguckt. Also, der Slux-Mann ist auch irgendwie ein
bisschen immer da, wo er sein muss. Du kannst ja durch den Smoke spotten. Wir waren auch
fast drin und keiner ist mitgekommen. Was willst du denn hier machen? Trash. Trashbalancing.
Was willst du tun? Genau, der echte Gangster. Aber solange wir Erster sind, ist okay. Da
kann ich nur wirklich nicht viel mehr machen. Oh, der Heli ist gecrashed. Das ist excellent.
Ich war nachladen. Fuck. Das war nicht excellent, dass der Heli gecrashed ist. Das kam vielleicht
schon mal ein bisschen vor. Vielleicht wäre ich auch gerätzt. Nee, wahrscheinlich nicht.
Die kommen ja auch nicht vorwärts. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14,
15, 16, 17, 18, 19, 20, 21, 22, 23, 24, 25, 26, 27, 28, 29, 30, 31, 32, 33, 34, 35,
36, 37, 38, 39, 40, 41, 42, 43, 44, 45, 44, 45, 46, 47, 48, 49, 50, 51, 52, 53, 52, 53,
54, 55, 56, 57, 58, 59, 60, 61, 62, 63, 64, 64, 65, 66, 67, 68, 69, 70, 80, 100, 90,
90, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15, 16, 17, 18, 19, 20, 19,
von wo denn schon wieder
aller game please und heute wieder belebt man ein bisschen
ok achtung spawn spawn lass mich spawn lass mich spawn also ich weiß nicht was mit dem
shotgun slug mann los ist ehrlich gesagt aber der ist irgendwie was merkwürdig dran
ok der heli ist weg vielleicht probieren wirs nochmal über die andere seite
ne wir probieren es gar nicht check jetzt vorbei mal schauen ob wir das defended kriegen mal
gucken ob rebalanced wird wie findest du die neue pass of exile season ich habe noch nichts
gespielt wir gucken jetzt mal ob rebalanced wird wenn ich rebalanced wird gehen wir auf
die andere server da wirds wahrscheinlich noch schlimmer
ja ne da machst du nix gerade du warst ja auch komplett trash team und trash balancing
die logik auf steam veröffentlichen ist ja das ist bescheuert vor allem wenn du es auf
steam kaufst musst du immer noch origin starten es ist komplett komplett sinnlos es lohnt sich
eigentlich überhaupt nicht auf steam zu kaufen außer halt nur dass man in seiner steam collection
drin hat wenn man das irgendwie toll findet keiner mag origin oh ich kann euch sagen wir waren ja
auf der gamescom damals bei der g2 a presse konferenz oder event oder wie man das nennen
mag also die haben echt die haben ganz schön geflamed gegen origin und origin mag die nicht
und und die mögen origin nicht und ea mag sie auf jeden fall auch nicht ja klar das hält er aus
der typ kommt gleich da oben runter und bashed mich fack der ist da oben da machst du nix da
machst du nix hier ist ja so ein druck dahinter von den gegnern da kommt sie hier kommt du
kommst keinen meter keinen meter lang mein trinkhaus geht gar nicht aber die liegen schon ok so ist
echt also balancing ist echt trash balancing ist mega trash omega trash ist omega trash alter
ist ja gut jetzt komm mal her so schwer zu überleben ist es hier auch nicht ich überlebe
seit drei minuten ok außer der helikett mich und alle sterben sie spielst du lieber attacker
oder defender auch eigentlich mindestens attacker attacker attacker ist mir lieber legit trash
server aber die haben wir auch recht schnell hier gehabt ich dachte dass ein gegner
was so bettel viel interpolation alda so an das alda so mal gucken ob es jetzt excellent
balancing absolut top guckt euch das mal an by the way warum haben die eigentlich neli
und wir das letzte mal nicht da springt garantiert einer ab von also wenn die das clever machen
oder nie war das der ist dass das der singles jetzt heli oder ob es noch spiele in hartline
gibt ja tatsächlich es gibt ein server mit domination der hatte glaubt er hat uns ein
heli es gibt einen surfer mit domination in hartline noch ein server das war es ripp
welcher war denn das jetzt von vorne einer war gar nicht der heli man also das balancing
ist hyper trash gerade wir müssen übrigens auf die andere seite weil die da grad hardcore
rein proschen ich versuche hier mein gott schießt doch mal gegen deiner mit
die sind da im haus drin ok nice das könnten wir diffusen kriegen
lass mich bewegen ich muss mich bewegen sonst waren die mich platt jetzt sind sie auf der
anderen seite ach ich soll mich aufgesprengt ey gala scheiß alter das ist wirklich balancing
auf doom gerade da hell hartline ist glaube ich ein surfer gibt's meinung zu battlefield
eins durch meinen fall genauso wie battlefield fünf ok trash surfer ich suche mir neun obbei
wir jetzt die runde soweit schon gespielt haben ich mein das ist wieder so eine trash
runde wie das letzte mal auf dem aber im peak defense die war auch voll für den arsch
was machen die anderen so was lass mal kurz gucken wo könnten wir dann noch hin der ist
voll der moment peak only muss nicht sein rush classics gehen wir mal auf den rush classics
es gibt zum abendessen es gibt wahrscheinlich pizza
aber das ist nicht so ganz ganz raus so nacki zufall ist noch da mich hab selber gewechselt
kein bock mehr auf den krack da gehen wir nachher drauf wenn vielleicht das team balancing
ein bisschen besser ist ob wir sind attacker wahrscheinlich auch kack balancing ich hab
den jake aber ich ich sehe nix
was ist denn hier los bitteschön ich blick nicht mehr durch sind wir sind attacker mitten
in der base kann das sein wir sind attacker mitten in der base dann sollten wir noch mal
lege hände machen so langsam aber sicher
auf die range zu kontesten ist doch der jaguar pz ist am start
hier ist auch jetzt schlechte pussy ach wir sind schon eine base weiter das ist nicht
dass wir in der base stehen sondern dass die gegner in unserer base stehen verstehe
ich sehe nix sonne sonne please
ok die können doch von hinten drüber
wir wechseln mal das quad wir wechseln mal dahin wo die besseren sind ok das ist doch
schon mal was gesporn kann ich bei keinem da ich hab ich hab nix gesagt mit was besser
sind dankeschön er ist poggers
poggers
oh noch mal wer will es wissen haben die instant ist das instant vehicle respawn
könnte es instant vehicle respawn sein weil er war ja sofort wieder da der heli
heli mann fliegt doch mal wo anständiges hin
heli mann
fliegt mal zu den gegnern
heli mann mach mal
hier ist übrigens aus hier kann ich nicht raus
excellent heli mann
by the way seit wann kam er denn hier lang
das ist mir neu
ah ok wahrscheinlich werden von der seite gleich geowned
oh da steht die langosta langosta oder wie auch
excellent big brain plays alda
wir verstecken uns jetzt hier einfach wird niemals jemand finden
top secret top secret
und sieht keiner das ist absolut unmöglich uns zu sehen
das hast du nicht gedacht dass sich einer unter
oh nein
gut
come on pra server please
es kann doch nicht sein dass die runde am start ist und ich bin erster
die runde war schon komplett durch
was ist das für ein server hier
was ist das für ein server
monkaS sag mal
was so ok ok
also ne können wir gerade mal einen server haben wo ganz normale teams sind die ganz
normal spielen
ok ok
was ist hier los
der chinese ist wieder da
den kenne ich der war gestern auch am start schon auf einem server wo ich gespielt hab
der chinese
ok
die wenn jetzt
so next
krasser slide um die ecke
game hallo
bleib hier wir müssen
macht diesen kark robot kaputt
was
wie hat er denn diffused wie sollen das bittchen gehen
erst mal mit dem granatwerfer reingeklatscht wie sau aber nein diffusor kein problem wir
diffusen
nein alter bewegt euch
bewegt euch
das kriegen wir schon hin
ok ok ok nice nice nice nice nice
die gehälle
ok ich leg nicht mehr
nein ich leg nicht mehr
da kommt unser lhw ran jawoll
jawoll
komm mit dem lhw komm mit dem lhw
und dann und dann an die dann an die rakete dran jawoll excellent
perfekt
mach jetzt lege henne
sag mal kann kann man von hinten das mal irgendwie klieren
ok ich geh jetzt rüber
die müssen eh über das dach kommen
ok nice wir haben es excellent
es ist anstrengend gerade saved
da kommt gleich was ihr dürft nicht so offen laufen
weil ich sehe halt dank dem ganzen geplitze nix
ok big brain plays jetzt
ok was auch immer vorhalten nicht
vorhalten nicht vorhalten
ich habe alle ranges ausprobieren hat nichts getroffen
wait a minute
moment trick 17 ich rapp den ich rapp den jetzt
was holen wir uns jetzt
nein man darf nicht von vorne ein fack man ich dachte warum darf man dieses kack auto
von vorne nicht einsteigen jetzt habe ich dem gegner das ding repariert
naja gut was willst du machen
es hätte big brain sein können
der chineser
jetzt haben wir es übrigens kaputt gemacht
ich glaube das hat für so viel distraction gesorgt
dass die gegner voll aus dem konzept sind
warum habe ich eigentlich keine pg dabei
ok ich muss rüber
ok wenigstens haben wir das mcom gesaved
gehst du heute zu mcdonalds nee ich esse nachher pizza
wahrscheinlich
wahrscheinlich esse ich nachher pizza
ich habe schiss
der kopf war mann kommt von hinten
ich muss da von oben auf b gucken von oben auf b von oben auf b
easy haben wir doch
ich weiß ja was ich krass finde an dem game das ist so krass intens so im vergleich zu
den anderen zu battle field 1 und 5 weil es auch nicht das ist das ist permanent geht
da irgendwas
oder auch nicht aber meistens geht da was
konnte man sich in dem game schon was aus dem rucksack nehmen
nee konnte man nicht
monka monka monka monka
ok hinter die mülltonne
by the way ich brauche money
moni
ah ppega aimed ppega aimed ich war neben dran
ppega aimed nicht schnell genug gezogen
überleben überleben überleben überleben überleben
excellent
wo sind wir überhaupt
ha
wo sind wir
haben wir saft
saft saft excellent saft so gehts
die rechte base ist schwierig zu halten
ihr explodiert mir grad so viel um mich drum herum
äh alter sind die gegner jetzt oben oder unten oder unten oder oben
immer
mal kurz die ecke hier ab falls da gleich was rauskommt
die wissen ja nicht dass ich da bin
moment das war zu früh das war zu früh es geht noch nicht auf
jetzt jetzt zeige ich euch die stell die stellzrute deluxe zeige ich euch jetzt
falls es funktioniert und wenn einer stream snipe bin ich gefickt
äh einmal moni flashed please
moni
come on pro
please na gibts nicht
übrigens ich kann euch die route nicht zeigen
ja nicht blocken
also ich wollte euch ja die god route zeigen jetzt
es geht aber grad nicht weil da gegner im weg sind
come on
hier links am wasser lang ist die beste die beste route ever
guck pass mal auf langsam langsam
ich habe aber kaum noch moni
beste route hier ich sag's euch man braucht nur munition
man braucht nur muni und ich hab keine muni das ist das problem
ich wusste dass der von hinten kommt das ist die beste route jetzt bräuchten schalldämpfer
mit muni hätten wir die jetzt richtig weggeklatscht
ich mein so geht es natürlich auch
big brain flanks
schnallber schnallber schnallber der hat mich gesehen
der kommt jetzt hin da steht die luftabwehr
das spiel ist voll anstrengend aber aber nicht so wie warzone warzone ist abfuck anstrengend
das ist einfach nur anstrengend und so dass es gut dass es gut passt
oh das das wird das wird das wird abenteuerlich hier
das wird abenteuerlich da mit dem m track reinzufahren
ich sag's euch mit stream sniper nicht möglich das zu machen
aber ansonsten beste na übrigens doppel squad cover ich nehm danach mal ich nehm danach
mal ammo squad ammo wir brauchen unbedingt mehr mehr ammo
oder besser gesagt mehr ammo ist immer besser als weniger ammo
ich weiß massive massive big brain logik
der jeep man
sag mal ist das ist das instant respawn ist das instant respawn
ja wir gehen wieder zu unserem poggers zu unserem poggers zu unserem poggers versteck
na wo seid ihr ihr könnt ihr könnt bei mir spawn alles gut
spavent bei mir spavent
habe ich keine granate mehr ich retz dich alter ist gut ich retz dich
komm um die ecke komm da raus
ausgerechnet jetzt wo ich nachgeladen habe
hatten die ein glück hatten die ein glück nein da hatten die ein glück dass der rw durchgefahren
ist ich hatte alle weggespray allesamt weggespray
poggers spawn beacon easy win
aber es ist easy der anfang war schwierig der anfang war echt hart hart erkämpft
so jetzt kann ich mal chat gucken aber die muss man sich ja so konzentrieren bei gibt
es den kaboom und den friseur noch ja gibt es beide noch
vom kaboom habe ich vor einem monat ungefähr was gehört vom fabian höre ich ab und zu
mal immer was heinrich acht monat excellent subscription
sehr nice hat mit dem release auf steam eigentlich mehr spieler ja ein bisschen so 5 6 rush server
beide die schiel tv app für twitch sound tv bock doch die werbung was
ich habe die app noch nicht ausprobiert also was ist was ist da die das folter vorteil
von dieser app im vergleich zu extra twitch oder wie das ding heißt
darf ich hier überhaupt über twitch werbung blocken ne ne leute guckt euch alle werbung
an alle twitch werbung angucken
wir gehen jetzt in das auto rein und dann fahren wir
vorne hin und schießen mit der mg den heli ab
und wenn der heli aber der heli fliege mal fliege mal auf zack ist schießt er uns vorher
ab
das ist der strats excellent strats
poggers strats poggers baguette strats ich hole dich
nein ich hole dich nicht schauen wir mal wo die gegner angestellt
ja sag mal wieviel bock hättest du auf neues battlefield das sich ordentlich spielt
ist einfach nur viel oder besonders viel
extra viel excellent viel hätt ich da bock drauf leute
ich weiß dass ihr da seid weil ihr da seid gehe ich da auch nicht
hin und ich stelle es euch jetzt auf dem fenster weg
nein und wenn wir verlieren das m kommen wie geht denn das wir haben noch geschreddert
gerade ja ich finde der vierer geht mittlerweile ich glaube ich glaube objektiv wtf das denn
verloren ich glaube objektiv gesehen ist mittlerweile
battlefield 4 das balancere und umfangreiche bessere game aber mein herz schlägt nach
wie für für battlefield 3 ja leute
bringst beste spot ich zeige euch mal ex exquisite exquisite spot
hier exquisite spot ist ja excellent huge brain spot
leichter big gebrainu wir müssen nur gucken dass hier nichts
durchläuft und und lege hände mal
auch kopf raus machen macht den kopf raus macht den kopf raus
oder das gegner mir vorbeigerannt gerade das gegner mir vorbeigerannt
hier müssen wir ein bisschen um positionieren ist nie verkehrt
ok wir sind ein bisschen viel vorne glaube ich glaube die gegner sind schon hinten am
starter wir sollten mal ein bisschen zurück
oder auch nicht schwierig zu sagen schwierig zu sagen wie viele da gerade durchkommen ok
da hinten sind einige gestorben da gehen wir mal kurz gucken
ich sehe da jetzt kein lege hände machen warte sag mal
krieg nur ich das gerade ab
was ist hier los das ist ja nur um explodieren
es ist ja nur um explodieren um mich drum herum
ich habe keine muni mehr fack need need muni
ok ich muss jetzt vorgehen was killen
ok pistole sagt da ich hätte vielleicht eben sollen
battlefield bed company zwei pistolen hätte ohne problem über die range machen kann
ppega nae
sind wir hier dann am start
excellent spot
es ist erstaunlich wie gut man die helis in dem game rausschießen kann
also wenn sie auf einen zu fliegen oder kommt da kommt ein m track
ich hab da gerade einen m track gesehen vor uns
der liegt glaube ich gerade der eine der überlebt hat kann das sein
lass mich hoch
manchmal fackt mich das an alten battlefields ab dass das movement nicht richtig funktioniert
äh
finden wir noch easy server ja ja ja relativ easy
what von wo war das denn
was macht der da
da ist er voll am arsch
monkaS
mein game sound ist gerade verschwunden deswegen war ich gerade etwas irritiert
aber also wo kommt das her mit dem heli wo ist der denn
ist das die neue big brain pro posi mit dem heli die kenne ich noch gar nicht
die war mir so noch nicht noch nicht bewusst die heli posi dass das das ein ding ist
kenne ich noch nicht
was wäre stream snipe chat
das mit dem game das ist so alt dass stream sniped keiner
da stream sniped keiner
warum haben die attacker eigentlich so viel helis gerade
das war eine ziemlich doofe idee
hier rauszugehen weil der gegner mtrack fährt gerade ans mcom
what the fuck
meine güte äh das ist der wahnsinn die bechen gerade voll durch
wie sind die spielerzahlen aktuell geht 5 6 server 5 6 server voll
ansonsten halt auch nicht mehr allzu viele server da
müssen gucken dass hier keiner flank flankerino macht
macht aber anscheinend keiner
by the way das ist moment Leute wisst ihr noch ob das ein 64 mann server war oder war
das ein 48er
48 64
ich kann da nicht hin
unmöglich dass ich da hingehe wenn ich schnell hier bin ich direkt vom mtrack
gepusht
ok das war ein bisschen viel jetzt
64 ach deswegen ist da so viel los weil das ein 64 mann server ist
achso ich hab mich schon gewundert kann doch nicht sein dass an jeder ecke so ein scheiß
gegner ist
aber doch kann wenn es ein 64 mann server ist
äh battlefield ich würde übrigens gerne hier hoch
ja das ist kein wunder ich war im kopf die ganze zeit noch bei 32 oder 48 mann
aber vielleicht ist er auch nicht voll ja ok das
eigentlich da war extrem viel los gerade für meinen geschmack
by the way wir nehmen jetzt mal statt cover nehmen wir mal ammo
dass sich das lohnt
diese squad perks fand ich übrigens eine ganz gute idee im nachhinein
tschü tschü tschü tschü baited
tschü tschü tschü tschü machen wir mal hier auf
tschü tschü tschü tschü baited eigentlich war es doof dass ich aufgemacht hab dann hört
man nix mehr
naa rechts steht natürlich noch einer
aber ich glaub das geflänke kann man nicht so richtig machen mit 48 mann
by the way ist immer aufgefallen dass die animationen teilweise extrem rumspacken
dass die dass die gegner quasi mit dem elbogen des gewehr halten und sowas
aber das machen die schon immer in dem game also das ist schon ist schon immer so kaputt
wie der lebt noch ok
alles klar schon mal wieder battlefield 3 zu sehen
ja ich hab die letzten tage öfters mal gespielt das macht macht echt bock das game
es hätte natürlich seinen scham wenn die uns grad nicht so extrem zerficken würden
ich hab die letzten tage öfters mal gespielt das macht echt bock das ist schon immer so
kaputt
ja ist klar der ist dabei nicht gestorben wieviel soll man noch draufballern startet
man das übers battle log ja
close quarters gibt's genau ein server der ist vorhin als ich geguckt hab zur hälfte
voll gewesen
ich bin ja schon von ihm runtergeswitcht grad schon
was machen die dudes ist das wirklich die neueste die die neueste strat die von der
ich noch nix gehört hab
was rumgeflänke da mit dem heli
das ist mir echt neu ich kenn das nicht du siehst sie ja noch nicht mal
ich rette euch
und ich auch
ja immer noch battle log
what the fuck der ist ja nicht mal sichtbar der heli
aber dafür machen sie echt wenig kills für dass das die hier so krasse
oh danach kommt metro leute danach kommt metro
da ist ein m track bei uns gefahren im spawn
wir können ja eh nicht viel machen
weiter weil gab's hier nicht irgendein trick ich krieg's nicht mehr zusammen
ich hol dich gab's hier nicht irgendein trick
ich hoffe der ist tot
die retten sich echt gut hoch
der ist noch dran eins zwei drei vier fünf kann aber was sterben
lol die geilen schneiber
ok ok hinten rum können wir schon mal nicht
wie stirbt man an der stelle hier
oder auch nicht
wir müssen wieder vor wir müssen wieder vor
wir sind schon wieder durch ja
what the fuck ist was ist hier los
ich check ich blick nicht mehr durch
ich blicke legit nicht mehr durch
was
what the fuck ist hier los
danach kommt metro leute wenn ihr gedacht habt jetzt
das hier ist schon clusterfuck
dann sag ich mal wartet wartet mal metro ab
dann ist ganz vorbei
ich sehe vor lauter gestaube gar nichts mehr
what the fuck von wo
aber danach ist metro oh das wird schlimm
das wird schlimm leute wir müssen wir müssen mal einen anderen
wir müssen mal einen anderen ansatz wählen hier jetzt
und zwar
oh fuck die kommen hier durch wir müssen mal hier anderweitig
die gegner killen
oh nein nein nein die helis fucken so krass ab
die helis lasst mich durch
wall bang
den habe ich gerade noch mal geholt
fuck den hätte ich holen müssen erlegt jetzt
nein mach doch keine kack animation alter
keine pepega animation machen einfach killen
was
fliegt einfach die ganze map in die luft
habe ich ja gerade den auskenn fuchs aus dem server gesehen
auf dem server gesehen
stimmt das
Habe ich doch gar nicht den Auskennfuchs gesehen oder habe ich mich verkickt, äh verkuckt
nicht gekickt?
Den kennen wir nämlich aus dem Stream, den Auskennfuchs, wo ist er denn?
Da ist er, der Auskennfuchs!
Ich dachte doch der Name kommt mir bekannt vor.
Also dass das M-Com tatsächlich noch ne Bombe dran gebraucht hat verstehe ich nicht.
Da ist so viel explodiert und in Bad Company 2 wäre das M-Com auch schon kaputt gewesen.
Weil in Bad Company 2 konntest du die M-Coms zerstören mit Häusern einstürzen lassen
und genug Damage drauf machen.
Da gab es Snipe, in Bad Company 2 gab es Sniper, die haben nichts anderes gemacht außer die
komplette Runde durch ihr Mörser Scope geguckt und aufs M-Com gelasert.
Das war sehr spannend, muss das gewesen sein.
Die Runde war nicht gut, nee nicht wirklich.
Die hatten auch einen kack Heli die Gegner, die haben den Heli durchge- anführlich geklitscht
bis zur letzten Base und dann haben sie am Arsch der Welt rumgeflogen.
Ohje Metro, ich hoffe wir kommen durch die erste Base durch, erste Base ist bei Metro
immer so ein Ding, erste Base ist immer so ein Ding, erste Base ist schwer und Metro
neigt auch so zum Spawn-Rape, Alter geht mir immer aus weh ich alle, der Typ ist fast tot
ich geh da jetzt rüber, wir haben auf der linken Seite ziemlich frei, aber Metro musste
von Anfang an übeles Action machen, die Metro Beta war poggers mit dem LLV, ganz
ehrlich, ich bin der Meinung der LLV wäre auf Attacker Metro immer noch gut gewesen.
Hinter mir Leute, guckt doch mal, hier kann doch nicht sein, wir sind so durchgepusht,
die müssten aufs Maul kriegen die Gegner, kann nicht sein dass der hier rumstellt mit
seiner Pistole und Kreisel, ja also ich hatte so oft schon Probleme auf Metro die erste
Base zu holen, dass ich im Nachhinein denke war der LLV in der Metro Beta doch nicht verkehrt,
oh guck mal da, das ist jetzt unsere Chance, wir müssen B halten und nachdem die jetzt
rüber gehen, nachdem die kleinen Kacknoobs jetzt rüber gehen zu, nein, die haben diffused,
das ist meistens das Kommando, wenn man eins gelegt hat muss man gleich zum anderen und
Metro 64 man ist auch das Problem man kann nicht richtig durchflanken, weil irgendjemand
sieht einen immer, irgendjemand sieht einen immer, ne, der sieht nicht tot aus, pff, ok
ja Smoke wäre eine gute Idee, please push team, da hat er recht, da hat er voll und ganz,
oh wir haben geplantet, ok, dann müssen wir jetzt wieder auf A probieren, hoffen dass
die, dass die B hinkriegen, ich so press mal einfach in die Richtung, Granate auf B kann
auch nicht schaden, da will irgendwas rumflanken, vielleicht haben wir Glück, da schneibern
so viele Dudes, ich hole dich, ok ich hole dich nicht, da kommt was, ich sehe nicht, ok
jetzt aber, Schmargerino, Alter ich hole dich, ok, ist gut, hab ich denn eben uns gerade
den Gegner gesehen, was ist denn da unten los, Jolo Ritz, der war gar nicht schlecht, so dumm
es so dumm es ausgesehen hat, die müssen sich jetzt 5 Sekunden auf uns konzentrieren
und das M-Com konnte in Luft, siehste, ey ich sag's euch, der Ritz, der hat vielleicht
sogar das M-Com gebracht, weil die komplett, komplett desorientiert verwirrt gewesen sind
die Gegner, ok cheat, 6 Kopf war das, next level place, übrigens links ist immer noch
ein Typ, Dude, ok das ist, der ist tot, haben wir ja Schneiber, so lass mal kurz mein Big
Prane channelen, also was war ein guter Weg nochmal in Metro, ich glaub, warte mal, der,
der und dann rechts, ne, ich bin nicht mal so richtig am, ich retz euch, excellent place
ah, ah, ah
was, das haben die, das haben die gerade überlebt, das Reingespray, guckt euch mal den Scorestreak
an grad, nein, nein, nein, ich blick nicht mehr durch, Alter, Metro, Metro MonkaS, MonkaGigaMetro,
warte mal, ich hab extra den einen schon aufgehört anzuschießen, weil ich mir gedacht hab, der
fällt jetzt um, aber da war Suppression wieder am Start, 64 Mann, ja Cluster, Cluster, fuck
Deluxe, nicht sterben, nicht sterben, nicht sterben, nicht sterben, ja, excellent, Cluster,
fuck Deluxe, Metro, Alter, okay, andere Seite, was ist hier los, Alter, Alter, Alter, Alter,
was ist hier los, MonkaS, du hast gar keine Zeit so lange zu sprayen, bis du siehst, dass
einer stirbt, du musst einfach auf Google sprayen und hoffen, dass du äh
wir warten jetzt einfach hier.
What, wie hat der mich denn gesehen, sind da Nades überhaupt erlaubt, klar, deswegen
ist das auch so ein krasser Cluster, fuck, weil der Nades spam auf du, man, an S64, man,
Ola Kizu bist du raus oder haben sie dich balanced, haben sie dich balanced oder bist du raus,
ich hoffe, wie die alle das Team flamen, what, ah Feuer, excellent, ja, Battlefield gibt's
gerade ziemlich günstig, was ein Cluster, fuck, guckt euch das an, mega null, oh mega
null, wir machen jetzt big brain plays, okay, wie auch immer, er mich da gesehen hat, das
ist übrigens the way, also so muss man was machen, warum sind die die ganze Zeit am Team
wechseln, der Hornst, mit Metro 64 Mann, also
meine Güte, Metro ist echt der Abfuck, vielleicht können wir die andere mal, da ist Leben in
der Bude, ja, Metro 64 Mann ist einfach grausam, Alter, ich krieg euch gar nicht alle gerätzt,
fuck man, what, jetzt wäre mal schön, wenn man mich alle gerätzen könnte, Moment, wo ist das,
das ist doch ganz hinten, das ist doch ganz hinten an der U-Bahn, okay, wenn die alle
Squads switchen, was willst du machen, dann gehen wir mal zum Auskennfuchs, der Auskennfuchs,
der ist ja huge, huge Auskennfuchs, jetzt kommt einer von hinten, okay, wir können,
können wir irgendwie anders rum, eigentlich nicht, ich weiß, wir können es mal probieren,
ob wir, nee, du kommst hier nicht durch, du kommst nicht durch, keine Chance, guck mal
der Chat, go ride tunnel noobs, super weak team, kack noobs, es ist Metro 64 Mann, was
erwartet ihr denn, easy, easy push oder was, was erwarten die Leute bei 64 Mann, Metro,
okay, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, okay, dann will ich, dass ich
ihn retze, auf, auf, auf, hier abgehen, kommst du nicht durch, meine Güte, das, die Map,
die map ich weiß überhaupt nicht wo ich lang soll ok links haben die jetzt keinen bock mehr
wie es aussieht
klar mit der pistole aber wieder belebt doch nice
im zug im zug metro metro 64 man
da kommen angekrabbelt
meine güte kann man hier mal irgendwie durchkommen
das sieht gut aus ja aber wird nicht die gegner die gegner weichen ich probiere was ich kann aber
die map monka metro aber echt
was ist hier los auf der war mein kopf alle metro
was macht der ausgehend fuchs da hat er den hat er den spin bot an
jetzt kommt die rechte rechten seiten place das ist hier gut
nein aber meine güte aus jeder aus jedem winkel aus jedem winkel
ok ok ich bewege mich jetzt nicht was meine güte ja ja ist gut ist gut lmg man
so ok der lmg man
also metro 64 man ist einfach nur cancer du kannst sie nicht bewegen wtf
ok ja einfach wir sprechen wir sprechen einfach
was kannst du sonst nichts machen siehst ja sonst nix
einfach besprechen jetzt einfach da machst du nix 64 metro
mein kopf das halte ich nicht aus auf dauer
nur motionplot das komplette game ist geplot
wollen wir uns noch die defense geben was hätten wir sonst noch so für server
am start übrigens essen ist gleich fertig
läuft da grad parallel operation metro
wenn an das volle programm ok wenn ihr wollt mal schauen was für den map danach
kommt aber 64 metro dauert auch immer so lang gay instant ban
wenn du sowas heute im klantek hast oder so ist gleich gleich instant ban weil wenn
es im video drin ist gibt es dann wahrscheinlich stelle mir vor ich nehme
ein video auf von einer heißt gay im klantek da ist gleich die youtube polizei am start
homophob klantek copyright und und community strike ist raus
gleich gleich vorbei stream geht stream dauen stream dauen youtube dauen twitter dauen
instagram dauen obwohl ich gar kein instagram profil habe aber für für zukünftige sachen
dauen wenn du wenn du da pride drin steht hast
ist was anderes das ist ok
aber die uns machen so platte weil irgendwie keine frontline da ist die halbe halbe klassenfahrt
schule macht ausflug wo sitzt denn der dude rum
ich muss rüber die wenn wenn die irgendwo durchgehen dann hier an b sage ich doch
wir müssen hier mal weg die sind ein bisschen zu aggressiv da vorne
sind wir ein bisschen zu akut da drüben ist übrigen gegner da okay das war ein guter
war ein guter versuch war ein guter versuch
ich habe halbe halbe ich habe immer ich habe immer 800 maus dpi
und wo ist der denn 800 maus dpi und dann je nachdem wie es sich ordentlich anfühlt
ich habe okay das war doof ich habe meistens also in den meisten games außer in battlefield
habe ich einmal mein mousepad lang für einen 360 ich glaube dass mein mein mein fail dass
die gelegt haben okay wir haben diffusen excellent ich sehe
da übrigens rechts den gegner der hat mich geblockt jetzt blitz
immer woanders hin gucken ob ich ob ich mich irgendwie hier
vortrauen kann bei 64 man metro okay easy
nein nicht da hoch rutschen da kommt auch die granate geflogen der ist einfach auf
den felsen hoch gerutscht gerade sollte doch gar nicht
er hatte kein bock zu sterben auch okay alles klar
in battlefield habe ich ein bisschen weniger sensitivity einfach weil battlefield so schnell
ist einfach weil battlefield so schnell ist
battlefield dankeschön
ich war um die ecke battlefield ja in battlefield ein bisschen weniger ein bisschen höher weil
battlefield ist halt da geht halt laufend irgendwas
noch mehr clusterfuck leute noch mehr clusterfuck es reicht doch nicht dass wir metro gespielt
haben wo will der denn hin wir wollen auch noch
bazaar spielen ist auch nicht genug da kommt ein plant
ein plant robot
monka giga was ist denn hier los ich weiß gar nicht vor wo
okay jetzt drücken sie gut rein das ist teilweise schon ein bisschen verbackt
schieß drauf es geht nicht kaputt nein wir machen wir machen als als nächstes machen
wir auf jeden fall grand bazaar grand bazaar muss grand bazaar muss
wir haben dreimal ammo scheiß wir haben dreimal ammo squad squad cover brau mal dreimal
ammo ist müll
ja habe ich gar nicht drauf geachtet
ich kann mich an das timing nicht mehr erinnern wann die hier angekommen sind
war da was
die clusterfuck included leute
clusterfuck included
clusterfuck
die sind ja hier schon durch
alter du kommst ja hier überhaupt vom timing nirgendwo durch granate und der moment läuft
da hinter dir raus
was willst du hier alles machen
da machst du nix hier gerade
kommst nicht das ist halt ist ja gut ist halt wenn das gegnerische team besser drückt dann
sieht so aus
hier haben wir uns 20 minuten die die zähler ausgebissen
guckt euch mal an die die leichenberge da
war ja das stürmt ja wie gesagt das ganze klassen das ist hier wirklich schüleraustausch
wir gehen hier mal rüber kurz
wie genau hat er das gemacht
ich habe hinter mir gesehen aber
und er weiß es ok wir brauchen auf jeden fall mehr retzes
hacker mann muss hacker mann gewesen sein
grand bazaar ich will grand bazaar oder sandcrossing
grand bazaar ist 4a clusterfuck never ends
by the way die legen jetzt hier klein oder auch nicht
ok ich muss dahinter die poschen hier wie verrückt
es sind einfach zu viele
was war mit dem typ los
ne ne ne b kriegen wir eh nicht mehr kannst vergessen aber die kommen hier gleich lang
der typ chat wieder
m191 freischalten ist die nicht die ist doch die voll anlockt oder
nicht die voll anlockt m191
was
Ach war das die wo man Battlefield Veteran sein musste ok ja dann weiß ich auch nicht
Ok die Base lässt sich ziemlich gut halten wenn man es ordentlich macht
Oh die sind ja schon rangepusht oh fuck
What the fuck ich komm da hoch und ich bin schon da
Da geht doch irgendwas nicht mit rechten Dingen hier gerade zu
Oh geil Granat hat was gekillt
Ok wo hockt denn der im Gang ok der Gang ist ist schlecht im Gang ist man ist man down
Gang sagt
Ok du hast hier gegen die Gegner keine Chance die
Poschen uns weg
Was kriegen wir B noch
Ne also gegen die Gegner haben wir echt keine Chance
Wir drücken uns krass weg da kannste nix machen
Ich hab übrigens die ganze Zeit jetzt hier schon seit ein paar Minuten mein Essen über
mir stehen ich muss gleich was essen
Ich weiß aber nicht ob wir nicht Grand Bazaar nochmal machen sollen
Und ich weiß auch nicht ob wir den Server nicht wechseln sollen
Weil die letzten paar Runden haben eigentlich ziemlich ziemlich gesackt
Eines der Probleme die man sowohl in Bad Company 2 als auch in Battlefield 3 und teilweise
4 hatte ist dass die Runden teilweise über dass sie nicht
dass sie nicht einfach nur anballet sind die Runden sondern teilweise komplett
Ungleichgewichtig also also so Gegner die in 5 Minuten die Map komplett machen und das
andere Team scheitern an der ersten Base
Wobei ich sagen muss auf der anderen Seite ich habe auch keine Probleme damit
Also wenn ich wenn ich dann auf der anderen Seite bin das
Ist mir dann auch egal Alter pusht mich nicht
Guckt euch mal die Gegner an
Ich komm um die Ecke aber die wussten wahrscheinlich da ich da bin
Was wird's Moment ich hab immer noch nicht wir brauchen Squad Squad Cover
Vielleicht können wir zumindest an der letzten Base noch ein bisschen was machen
Keine Chance
Da an der anderen Seite wenn wir das schnell verlieren da können wir gucken ob es bei Bazaar
noch mal flutscht
Was ist denn wieder hier gespawnt
Mal gucken ob wir überhaupt noch aus dem Spawn können
Dann glaube ich gar nicht mal aus dem Spawn
Schön war dass ihr euch da alle bashen lasst ist in Ordnung
Oh Gott es ist ja schon am M-Com dran
Das können wir doch diffusen also wenn sich da mal einer barmherzig ist jetzt
Passt auf Moment was ich muss hier weg
Ich muss hier weg nichts wie weg
Schauen wir mal ob wir noch irgendwie hier rumkommen
Flankmaster okay das war zu viel Sprey und Prey
Sag mal können die mal sterben grade
Zu viel Sprey und Prey
Oh Gott ich wusste das jetzt runterpushen
Haben wir Eats das Game ja es sind ja nur noch 200 Tickets oder so was wir Eats haben
müssen
Alter wo sind die denn wieder
What the fuck
Voll knicken
Wo sind wir hier eigentlich grade
Oh da kommt ein Gegner
Mit aimen wir mal kurz
Die haben echt keinen Bock zu sterben
Ey komm rum
Ich camp jetzt einfach an der Ecke ab
Ich weiß nicht von wo
Hier kommt man guck mal die Tickets gehen runter
Ich will machen das kriegst 17
Boah hat nicht gehitted
Ihr habt nur noch einen Mkomm ich weiß
Ich weiß wir haben nur noch einen Mkomm
Aber grad haben wir sie ganz gut
Aber nur wenn man die direkt abfangen wenn sie hinlaufen
Wenn die komplett bis zum Mkomm ran pushen können ist vorbei
Achso ich dachte es ist ein Gegner
By the way ich hab den schon gesehen hinter mir
Ich wusste nur das ich grade am nachladen bin
Big brain move wallbang
Ich FC
Wenn die mal aufhören so zu springen.
Ah nein, ich dachte es war ein Team-Mate drin, richtiger Spraiser, ja muss, komplett gesprüht
und gebetet.
Oh, das ist schlecht, dass wir jetzt alle gestorben sind.
Nice Toast, excellent Toast, okay, ich traue mich hier nicht raus, Leute, ich traue mich
hier nicht raus.
Okay, es war eine schlechte Idee.
Au, au, au, lasst mich durch, lasst mich durch, Alter.
Die kommen hier durch, ich sag's euch, pass auf, pass auf, da kommt noch gleich noch was.
Meine Güte, ist hier was los, Alter, Hypermonker, what the fuck, BTF, Alter, Alter, Alter, Alter,
Alter, Alter, Alter, Alter.
Was ist hier los gerade?
Okay, 2 Stück, kannste nix machen, aber was da, das ist ja gerade das halbe Lager explodieren,
okay wenn die wieder in das haus kommen ist schlecht
oh nice nice nice nice
nein nein shit warum hab ich nachgeladen
erst mal gucken müssen
okay was haben wir hier
ah der machts gut der pusht schon mal vor
nice toast pro excellent
wahrlich excellent
auch hier gehts ja gar nicht hoch
ich hab keine ahnung wo es hier lang geht
wo ist hier was
ist hier was
ich versteck mich mal kurz
ich kann ich komme im kopf überhaupt nicht mehr klar ich komme im kopf überhaupt nicht mehr klar
richtig pepegaart
links links links
da oben sind noch mehr
es war ein wichtiger kill wir müssen die links halten
okay der ist tot das ist schon mal nice
hier zu retzen ist fragwürdig ich glaube ich hätte besser bessere winkel gehabt beim
reinsporn wir pushen sie wieder weg das ist sehr gut
okay ich muss hier weg
vielleicht 23 stick jetzt noch ich glaube hinter uns war hinter uns noch was ich hab
glaube ich was gesehen
man weiß nicht manchmal manchmal sitzen wir sonst wo
beide keine ahnung was hier abgeht ich halte ich halte einfach mit unsere leuten hier
wir müssen hier schauen dass sie nicht durchkommen
wir nehmen hier wieder den da
super ey nice wir haben das noch gewonnen hätte ich nicht gedacht
obwohl ich am anfang ein bisschen mehr hätte machen können war die letzte base wirklich
gar nicht schlecht
vor allem dass wir sie immer an den stellen gekillt haben wo sie sich festgesetzt haben
so musst du es machen
muss die killen dass sie ich meine sie bettel viel dreier gar nicht so einfach weil die
sich ja instant hoch retzen können 50 mal
muss sie immer an den stellen killen wo sie wo sie ihren nachschub haben weil wenn die
vom spawn laufen müssen ist das kein ding da kriegste hast du auch die chance die einzeln
zu erwischen wie du einfach die gleiche stimme wie vor zehn jahren das ja das liegt daran
weil ich vor zehn jahren auch schon 25 war dann also am gewissen alter glaube ich verändert
man die stimme nicht mal so viel
so jetzt kommt leute wenn ihr clusterfuck metro mochtet ihr werdet grand bazaar lieben jetzt
mal gucken was wir werden attacker defender
theoretisch attacker aber das ist nicht immer absich abwechselnd
hast du mal max payne gespielt alle alle drei ja super games
mein lieblings max payne ist das erste eindeutig weil es auch mal erstes max payne war finde
ich auch die beste story
jetzt ist die frage wer schneller da ist jetzt ist die frage wer schneller da ist
ok die gegner sind schneller da
es sind aber links nicht viele also wenn wir links gehen
auf bb ist viel viel wichtiger dass mich alle dass mich bs poggers
jawoll bs das ist die halbe miete bs die halbe miete
ok was auch immer oh nice ein retz
jetzt ist erstmal ein bisschen schwierig hier durchzukommen
eila ich sehe die gegner nicht mal huge kondom ok huge kondom
hi iq res
ich muss erwarten bis der ganze mist explodiert ist
oah der hat die weggesprayt der hat die big brain weggesprayt
da kommt klar kommt klar achtung die liegen um die ecke ich sehs da kommen wir nicht durch
pulle pulle oh wir sind ja schon ran excellent
poggers shit das hätte gut klappen können
alter was get2 tappt ist da also entweder hat er richtig gute sprays gekriegt oder da stimmt
was nett oda
ok ich bin grad so krass am sprayen und nix treffen mehr
ich höre links nehmen wir ein
ah shit von der seite richtig pepega im genau chat hier chat die ersten paar gehen schon
achtung achtung da kommt gleich was
wir müssen hier raus wir müssen auf die andere seite auf dieses komische ding da
da müssen wir hin genau da da müssen wir hin excellent da lass mich rauf da muss man
rauf bester spot bester spot
bester spot get wrecked oh meine muni meine muni ist bald leer
hier weg hier mal kurz ab eben dass da keiner mehr rankommt
gucken gucken ich seh nix ich seh nix ich brauche muni
ich brauche muni ich brauche munition
hier liegt doch bestimmt muni irgendwo muni ah excellent muni
jetzt kommt die abfuckbase übrigens im metro das ist die abfuckbase alter komm retz please
come on brah das ist die abfuck hier brauchst du einen guten panzerfahrer hier brauchst
du einen guten panzerfahrer dass das funktioniert oder du pust schneller als man bei verstand
ist die base ist die schwerste auf auf ganz warum sage ich eigentlich metro die schwerste
auf wasser auf der base gibt es nämlich tatsächlich nur zwei wege die funktionieren theoretisch
drei ganz links außen aber das ist eigentlich wieder zweite sind wir schon durch wir sind
schon durch excellent
nice ha ha ich habs gesaved ich habs gesaved
chaud wow
she Amy
ha ha ha
agricultural
yes
ha ha ha
ha ha
have
ha ha ha ha
ha ha ha
ちゃん
yeah
hahaha
haha
lake
lo
incompatible
you
did
dat
the
node
today
Ch-Ch-Ch-Ch-Ch-Ch-Baited
Ch-Ch-Ch-Ch-Ch-Baited
Die Gegner
Tja damit haben die nicht gerechnet, ne?
Tja, damit haben die nicht gerechnet, dass sie da von hinten mit den krassen Pistol-Snipes ankommen.
Okay, ich brauch Muni. Legt ihr vielleicht Muni rum?
Muni? Irgendwo? Muni? Da legt Muni. Ich sehs, ich sehs, hier legt Muni. Muni.
Hey, du, du, du, du hast Muni. Nein, irgendwo hier legt er, da vorne, da vorne legt.
Muni, Muni, nein, please, da, da.
Wir machen jetzt übrigens den, den besten, wir nehmen den besten Weg hier, da linksrum.
Das ist der beste, the way ist das, the way. Also get to tap, da hab ich immer noch so meine,
ob das so alles mit rechtem Ding zugeht. Wow, ausgerechnet jetzt kommt ein RPG geflogen,
Krasser Shit. Krieg ich vielleicht nen Rats?
Das ist tatsächlich der beste Weg hier, wirklich ohne Sch- Oh, warte mal, meine Waffe ist wieder leer.
Ah nee, ich hab so ein komisches, was ist denn hier?
Okay, lass mich, please respawn, ich will respawn, ich will respawn, ich will meine, ich will meine Klasse wieder haben.
Es gibt mir meine Klasse, excellent. RPG on Inf, Swift Rage, komplett sofort raus.
RPG on Inf.
Nice, nice, next, jetzt sind wir durch, jetzt sind wir durch oder auch nicht.
Ich brauch, ich brauch ne Ammo, haben wir ne Ammo?
Auf irgendeinen Grund Ammo. Wow, wir verschwenden ein bisschen viel hier.
Wow, der könnte mich aufhippen, also dieser get to tapped ist mir, ist mir verdächtig irgendwie.
Wallbang, Nate.
Da sind nicht viele, da sind nicht viele.
Ah, jetzt, jetzt schon, au.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, der stirbt jetzt, aber klar.
Oh big flank massive
die kommen hier klein die mussten ja kommen
wir müssten von hinten gucken okay ich rette euch ich rette euch nicht wir müssen von hinten
gucken okay und tschüss ich geh mal wieder raus hier ist hier ist zu viel los brauchen anderen winkel
hinter mir auf der straße sind auch noch welche dachte die sind weg weil irgendwo müssen wir
hergekommen sein was von wo von wo das ist unser laser typ da drüben
ich muss mal ein stückchen weg hier das mit zu zu aggressiv
andere seite
das ausgerechnet der dritte stehen bleibt und guckt unser team also die sind alle im
rahmen aber der get too teppt weiß ich nicht was mit dem ist oder auch nicht ob die auch die
letzte station halten jetzt wir gehen gerade ehrlich gesagt so ein bisschen die ideen aus
wir gehen gerade ein bisschen die ideen aus für ruten ich meine es gibt die straße und der
weg fertig mehr gibt es nicht das war es das war es mehr gibt es da nicht vielleicht kann
ich mit panzer fahren oder so aber die sind schon voll oh lege henne am start ja na klar
gerade da wo ich lang laufe am arsch der welt steht einer an der seite der hcm demuts ich will
eigentlich bei euch nicht sparen obik pratt doch nicht low-brain flank was spawns spawn tot
exzellent wo sei ich der tank mann der musste irgendwo sein
hinten ist noch einer ja sehr gut zugeflankt perfekt jetzt sieht man nichts mehr ich glaube
es war einer von uns exzellent so dass man nichts mehr sieht
hinter uns was hat er mich dann so schnell erwischt beim durchgang ich war auch schon
mal die kiste jetzt was soll ich denn machen ich komme nicht mal an das m kommen wir ran
muss man ranfahren wo ist der tank mann eigentlich was gibt
zu essen pizza pizza
okay hier geht schon mal nicht weiter ja ich muss nach der runde ich weiß ja ob wir
die defense runde noch spielen ich muss auch gleich essen
übrigens panzer ich gehe panzer auch nicht
guck mal oder vielleicht rankommen
auch dieses um die ecke springen muss ich mir abgehören das ist call of duty kack
darf man auf gar keinen fall machen das ist in bennett wieder triffst du nix
okay jetzt legen wir
lass mich durch wir haben die jetzt von hier ab
nein panzer ich sehe nix sehr exzellent sehr gut gemacht
ich dachte ich komme da irgendwo durch diffuse ja der panzer ist mir da vorgefahren ich konnte
nicht mal drauf schießen
jetzt müsste mal einer aussteigen dass man spawnen kann
okay oder auch nicht
verlieren wir das jetzt noch am letzten emm kommen
noch kontakt zum friseur klar immer mal wieder
auch letztens mal ich versuche mein glück
okay doch nicht bringt ja nichts aber reinrennen und sterben wir müssen die drüben weg machen
wir haben es echt noch verloren ich fasse es nicht schade dass es den team chat nicht
so zu sehen gibt weil der team chat der hätte garantiert jetzt moment wo ist das passende
emote habe ich keinen rage emote leute ich habe keine ich habe keinen rage und warum
das denn nicht ich weil ich nie rage ist doch so
ich habe echt kein rage emote ich habe gedacht ich habe irgendwie swift rage oder sonst irgendwas
aber habe ich nicht habe ich nicht
wollen wir uns die defense noch geben
also wie gesagt meine pizza ist schon kalt mittlerweile
jetzt sind scheiße 15 minuten steht
defense ist so eine sache die man kann wenn man den ersten push abhält wenn man den ersten
push abhält kann man eigentlich ganz gut erst mal hände waschbunker corona wenn man den
ersten push abhält kann man eigentlich ganz gut
was er erste base sogar schon halten
ich hätte ich wäre übrigens lieber auf auf der anderen seite gespornet weil ich rechte
seite wichtiger finde erst mal zu halten weil die kommen die e sauschlecht durch ja ok ich
habe versucht abzuhauen
also sie dürfen auf keinen fall an b ran
also bb kann man eigentlich wenn man wenn man es gut macht kann man b nicht richtig
verlieren
ja es müssen alle in b rein also b kann man granaten zuspermen
das ist eigentlich kein ding
also die die defense muss ich mir nicht geben also wer sich so dumm anstellt am ersten punkt
kann sie voll vergessen habe ich keinen bock drauf so ich esse jetzt was leute also die
erste punkt die fern zwei absolut fail ich esse jetzt was
bis denn
hier noch noch für heute
bis dann machts gut